head coach of the Clippers president of
basketball operations Doc Rivers back on
the program how we feel in today coach
well feeling pretty good then I would
rather you be talking about us but other
than that I feel great can you watch the
finals yeah I can you know there's some
years you don't watch on your watching
the middle of the summers but I
basically have watched every game i
watch the Oklahoma series you know which
is amazing series and then watch the
first two game show which I lubing the
coach of the Cavs you know I have a
vested interest in this series hey
coaches talk about this with the you
play Golden State and you think you're
doing pretty well and then all of a
sudden you look up and you were down
three now you're down 13 as a coach and
you've experienced this firsthand what
is that feeling like and how do you stop
it bro well I've got a great felon tell
you that you know you got to keep
playing them my Derek rate team and
there and I said just last year about
them they have the greatest shooting
backcourt in the history of the gay and
when you have that they're never out of
the gate because of their shooting and
you when you play them yet you feel like
you have to be great defensively
obviously but I think it'd be great
offensively when you play Golden State I
thought Oklahoma had the right at least
recipe for most of it when they are
attacking I think that's the right way
no one's done it enough to beat him four
times but I thought that was the right
way to play them do you think klay
Thompson feels he's everybody shooter
stuff is yo for sure there's no doubt
about that you saw that in the
three-point contest that's what you like
about them like you know we talked about
all their shooting and we you know I
think their defense gets overlooked a
lot I think the two things that people
miss mostly going state is how
competitive they are I mean they compete
on every possession that I I didn't
think it was closed last night the
competitiveness from
when you look at to want him to the
other team and yet through all that girl
competition they have a great chemistry
and their chemistry beats you as well I
brought this up to Jerry West he quickly
shot it down I said that you know Steph
Curry reminds me of a Pete Maravich with
more range and and Jerry said no it's
that's not not the comparison I don't
know if there is a comparison we love to
have a comparison to say this guy
reminds me of this guy I'm just not sure
who that guy is is there somebody that
you played against or you remember that
maybe steph sort of resembles well I
like I told his father he reminds me of
his father except where he couldn't
dribble enough that's it I mean his
father was a heck of a shooter and
probably people didn't realize it
because it could dribble like that and
my guess is when just up and answer for
little kids Dale decided i'm going to
teach these kids out of dribble I should
have done that I could have been this
i'm going to say do but i also look at
nash that I think Steve now and I think
steph has acknowledged that he looked up
to nash and the way he played and
Steve's ability to pass and have you off
balance to get those shots now he didn't
you know Steve Nash didn't have the
range that steph has but I do see a
little bit of similarity in in their
games is that a fair assessment no there
is I think mass is probably more of a
genius with assists and Incept I mean
does everything as well but I think Nash
is a little better in that way but I
think except there's so many other
things but you can see the similarities
for sure in Nash's game I think Nash has
influenced a lot of players you know
that is a sign of greatness when you see
a lot of other players after you retire
and they play similar to you and so that
tells you that NASA is a great player
thanks doc rivers Clippers head coach
has the Clippers style impacted your
coaching style what argument go state
style yeah yeah I'm sorry the Golden
State style house that has it affected
anything that you've done differently in
the
last couple years well it influences you
but I think the mistake people make
quite often in our league you know since
I'm in Hollywood I would say you know in
the movie business you know one person
makes a great movie and in it for the
next five years we see a bunch of bad
movies that are trying to be that one
great movie if you know what I'm saying
yes and I think it's done every year in
the NBA when a team wins it when we
wanted in Boston you know everyone tried
to copy that style and you know Golden
State has perfected their style and
there's no one this can be better at it
than them and so I love their movement
you know I think one of the things Steve
did was I always thought they were great
defensive team I don't think Marv
Jackson gets enough credit for what he
did for them defensively but what Steve
did he came in and really changed their
offense when you think that curry gave
up the ball almost twenty percent of the
time more last year than he did the year
before and he scored more points by
giving up the ball and he was MVP by
giving up the ball it just tells you how
great their movement is so with the
Commissioner talked about the
hack-a-shaq and that he wants to do
something about that why do you bring
that up to me uh-uh let me see let me
see your free throw shooter that's right
DeAndre Jordan can't shoot free throws
what do you think about that strategy
now can can you remove yourself as the
Clippers head coach having a guy who is
free-throw challenged and look at it
just as an analyst how are your opinions
different as the coach and as an analyst
with that getting rid of the hack-a-shaq
know they're pretty much the same but I
i would say it has evolved you know i
was one even with DJ I said publicly
that I didn't think they should touch
the rule but listen at the end of the
game we're in the business of we want
people to enjoy the product and it
doesn't look good the game state forever
when they happen and people don't enjoy
it I'm in favor of changing the room but
i'm not in favor of changing it
completely i don't think we should
completely bail out the shooter
we should have you know we've changed
this route before so it's not like we've
never changed it so I do think we should
alter it but not to the point where you
let them off the hook completely the
coach I don't understand that you could
have a guy who could shoot forty-five or
fifty percent over hand and if I said
you can shoot underhand and shoot sixty
percent they'd rather miss overhand then
make underhand well its like you with
the long putter dad you know a lot of
drills yes when a long putter was in
they didn't want to use it because it
looked bad I agree with you you know
when i play with the Hogs Rick Barry was
our a reporter or you know you did the
commentary of the games and and when he
shot with us all the time and it was
amazing to watch you know I haven't said
that I don't think it's as much
technique as it is mental I I'd really
believe that I think it's more of a
mental challenge once it gets in that
the head I think you can work on it all
day and you know you see very little
changes there have been some guys that
have been mentally strong enough to
break it but i I've always started it's
not former technique these guys do the
work i watch DJ shoot every day but I
think once again in to your head
mentally I think it becomes very tough I
know Muhammad Ali had a big impact on
your life and would love to hear your
thoughts first time you met him where
were you what was that like well I have
a great first time I met him I was being
recruited by a Louisville and in high
school and you know Denny Crum and their
entire coaching staff you know when they
did their house is it they looked in my
room and i only posted a head on my wall
where Muhammad Ali I didn't have a
basketball player a baseball player
anything was just Ali and I'm sitting at
home you know three or four days later
in the phone rings and it's a Leo you
know so that was my first I guess
meeting with him which was for a young
kid who idolized him I mean I cried the
night that he lost to Joe Frazier you
know so he's had a huge impact on my
life
I think he's had an impact on a lot of
people's lives and not just from boxing
it's more you know his humanitarian row
and you know I think for black kids
growing up in that time in the 70s I
think he made it all right you know I
said something similar that you know you
all right for me to be me you know you
never thought that that are you were
good enough you know growing up at times
as a kid and I think I'll he just made
it all right for you to be you and I
thought that was that was awesome from
him why and then you have to say no to
Louisville after that yeah and and when
they win the national championship here
only one guy leaves and I could have
just slipped right here you know but
listen al McGuire Rick Majerus and
grinder they're better recruiters I
guess oh then Ollie please the greatest
you know promoter of all time so dizzy
how long's a conversation last we're all
he's trying to convince you recruit you
to Louisville last probably a minute you
know minutes and he rude talk more just
about you know you wanna ask me any
question I wanted to ask him and know
what is the high school kids your noses
heck you know the typical stupid
questions that a kid would ask is what
you would ask what did you ask him well
the first thing was I asked him how tall
is he you know how long are your arms
you know when you hang up the phone and
you think about it later you're like wow
I blew that opportunity in a big way you
could ask him what's it feel like to get
punched by Joe Frazier I wanted to ask
that actually tell my friends I but I
didn't have the courage to so do you
tell your family like just your family
know that Ali's on the phone oh yeah my
mom and dad did know it was awesome and
you know obviously they were going crazy
you know back there was only one phone
in your hand yeah you know it's not like
we had a cell phone there's a phone that
was on the wall and that's the phone I'm
talking on you think about theirs
a footy person chance that the phone
could have been busy because everyone
anything bad about their well plus you
if you had two phones in the house they
could have listened in on the
conversation that's true that's the
great thing about cell phones i'll say
that hey Doc I was great to catch up
with you are you going to the Summer
Olympics I'm not uh you know we went I
went to last time but with the extra
rolls I gotta build this team damn yeah
you watching go to state right now yes I
think I have to work Thank You doc good
to talk to you again nice balcony here I
had stock rivers that's great stuff
continental tire coaches corner there
with Doc Rivers from rain to snow to Sun
everything in between Continental Tire
its best fire out there we love these
people continental tires engineering
tires extraordinary performance
reliability putting confidence into
driving for more information and the
location of a dealer near you visit
Continental Tire com continental tire
for what you do the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience